welcome everyone to a panel title the
top 10 mistakes of entrepreneurship
which is actually what we are not going
to cover today because as entrepreneurs
I think we're all very optimistic about
our prospects and I also think that we
learn a lot more from success than we do
from failure which is a little
counterintuitive but with that in mind I
have a bunch of questions that that I'd
like to lead off with for our panelists
who I'll introduce in a moment and then
we'll open it up to the group at large
with about 20-25 minutes to go how does
that all sound all right good well
joining me today are first on my left
Pradeep Cindi Pradeep after graduate
school joined the Palo Alto Research Lab
spark and worked a number of computer
architecture related issues there ending
up with a joint design with Sun
Microsystems for the creation of the
first multiprocessor and from there he
went on to create Juniper Networks and I
had the good fortune to work with fir
deep over the years so pradeep's left is
dan Aveda upon coming to the United
States dan created a product within a
company called Electronics for imaging
the original business IVF I I think was
on color management systems but then
created the fiery color printer
controller which he as a result of his
great design and hiring the people was
made the CEO and grew it from zero to a
500 million dollars in revenue and it's
a very successful public company today
from there he left and after taking some
time off started another company that we
were fortunate enough to back at
benchmark Apple called de croo which was
focused on encrypting disks and de croo
has
we've been acquired by a network
appliance to his left is Danny shader
after graduating from business school
here Danny joined what was a very
exciting industry at the time the
pen-based computing industry for a
company called NGO which some of you
might remember and then after go we
recruited him to join a startup that we
had back called kelabra software which
as you might imagine built collaboration
software and it was acquired by Netscape
Communications Danny went on to become a
critical member of the management team
at Netscape after Netscape he came to
work out of our offices to create a
company focused on electronic payment
and escrow called accept which four or
five months into the company
unfortunately was acquired by Amazon he
became a member of the management team
but I think the management team of
accept became the senior management team
of Amazon which which was a fasiq thing
which was the second time Danny had been
involved in a start-up where the
management team was acquired and became
the senior team of the acquire or that
doesn't happen very often
well after after that experience he came
back down from Seattle and started
restarted a company that had been
focused on a different area than the
email space called good technology some
of you might know it for for mobile
email and then to to Danny's left is a
national treasure Mike farm all my
partners and I have backed Mike five
times roughly which is an interesting
question we're going to get into about
serial entrepreneurship I don't think
cereal successful serial entrepreneurs
intend to be serial entrepreneurs that
just so happens they're interested in
particular ideas Mike starting his
career developing supercomputers and
from there started a company to do
microprocessor development which was
acquired before it even got started by
MIPS computer he he designed the
tl version of the mips microprocessor
which saved the company and it not been
for that MIPS never would have been
commercially successful and as you all
know that we've grown to be a very
significant piece of computer
architecture from they are founded
Rambis very successful company in the
memory space and then a program
chromatic which is hard for either of us
to say because it was one of the few
that didn't work out and most recently a
really interesting memory company called
matrix semiconductor which was acquired
by sendeth SanDisk just recently it's
the innovator in 3d memory technologies
for non-volatile memory and so with that
background if I can find my notes we'll
kick off the questions so giving that
you'll learn more from success than
failure if you all were to start a
company right now not good you ever have
an intention of doing it again but
what's the one issue that you would pay
the most attention to pay the most
attention to the people that I'm hiring
looking for when you do that i you know
i think that at companies especially
small companies when you put together a
team that is really really excels at
what they do you can you can do magic
and as we talked earlier of course you
know you can you can always fail even
when you have brilliant people if the
market fit of your products isn't good
so that sort of goes without saying but
but I you know I'd always bought the
highest value I'd give to be to the
people that I'm hiring yeah so I'll
quote Warren Buffett always says that if
you have a great executive team and a
terrible market a terrible market always
wins
I'm gonna understand agree with Pradeep
I mean the crew is called the crew as
Andy knows because we put together the
crew but I think the market is super
important and for startups markets have
to be very carefully defined first of
all you want the market that will end up
being big but that's not big at the time
that you start the company because if
the market is big by definition you
already have entrenched competitors and
dislodging entrenched competitors is too
hard to do in most cases so you have to
attack a market that is in high-growth
stage where it's quite small where the
company that you're late doesn't exist
or it doesn't even exist and then if it
doesn't looks even better by definition
you become number one immediately if
it's oh it exists you have to look a bit
harder to become number one but you
definitely want to only attack the
market we can be one or two I just you
know I always heard to subscribe to that
view that you shouldn't you should be
the first kind of market but I remember
being in business school and coming in
and seeing the CEO of where the founder
of Stratos come speak and sitting up
here and I said you know so why'd
Stratos was coming to date non-stop
parallel computing like tandem and I
said well why did you start Stratos went
and have existed and he looked at me he
said cuz tandem needed a competitor and
I remember at the time thinking that was
a really lame answer and of course I
knew so much but they did really well
anyhow later on when I got ready to
joined good and I'd talked to Andy's
partner Bruce and I was like how are we
gonna end up competing with rim they're
doing so well and he said every room
needs a competitor every market needs at
least two players and for us actually
it's been great to be a to be a follower
and to take advantage of the mistakes of
the leader but but the higher order
answer is it's the people it's the
people in the market obviously I mean if
I'd answered first I probably would have
said the people in advance or second
I'll give my own I do have an answer
though but it's idiosyncratic to me
which is I look now given my past for
technology that's very deep so something
that isn't probably even gonna be very
relevant maybe four five years or so but
that for which a lot you can get a lot
of intellectual property because that
for me that seems to work out the best
so that's it sort of the idea of city
syncretic answer from for me okay when
you think about what's most important so
the issue that you just the issues that
you all just went through how much time
do you spend on that relative to all of
the other issues that you have to
consider when you're starting your
business is it equal allocation do you
overweight one versus another we'll
start with you Mike since you have an
end
well again I love you I'll give the
idiosyncratic answers because I'm a
technologist and that's what I like
doing in fact that's what I spend most
of my time doing is thinking about the
technology and once it starts to get to
the point where I actually think there's
something there and it's plausible then
obviously the next thing to do is find a
stay on the Stanford
usually electrical engineering professor
to work with and another thing I've to
say is time management is one most
important skill that anybody in business
has to have in any line of work whether
it's an end he's going to work right and
it's just the main thing to do and
there's not a formula to open up and
says you develop 10% you devote five
percent for this and ten percent for
that and 20 percent for that it turns
out when you look at everything you have
to do it takes about 50 hours in a day
and you have less than that to do the
work so you just got to figure it out
somehow you never really have enough
time right second but you know in terms
of how much time you spend on this
particular issue clearly in my case I
spend a lot more time earlier in the
company than I did
as a company so I I think especially the
the jeans of the company gets set very
very early on and if you don't pay
attention to the early people you make
life very difficult for yourself
so upfront there's a lot more attention
it seems like some people try to do
everything on their to-do list doesn't
work for me but it may work for the
people who can multiplex more their
yachts for no good at it do you think
yeah different so much burners are good
at running their own companies and I
think almost by definition they have to
be better at managing their time did an
entrepreneur like me who has no
intention of running the company
I mean I'm terrible at it so I trust him
I feel that people work better at it and
and then I you know it's usually at
night when you're going to bed your
figure out what am I most concerned
about ok that's what I'm going to focus
on tomorrow I mean sort of how it it's
the anxiety release you think that their
person is small company than a large
company oh absolutely
I mean yeah I mean particularly now that
our company is getting to be a
significant size you know how I spend my
time is completely different I really do
have to think much more strategically
about how am i spend my head which is
mostly trying to figure out how other
people are spending time and and that's
a that's a real shift right from when
you're you know three guys in a dog
about of an Amazon no that was a rapidly
growing company at the time you got
there yeah but I was a bit big but when
I was there Amazon ran like a scrum I
mean it was it was it was fascinating to
be a part of something that big and
growing and that disorganized which was
a it at that stage in its growth was was
a very effective model it was sort of
people would come together for project
and they didn't move apart but the trick
with that model was just what's worth
was coming into that you either figured
out this weird subculture of how things
worked or you didn't if you did you
could be effective in the environment if
you didn't you get washed out and I
actually think Amazon washed out quite a
good quite a number of people who would
have been
affective had it been better organized
at the time we had went by the way
Amazon was growing and losing a ton of
money and then there was sort of that
phase where it got very disciplined and
I think it got more structured was able
to assimilate a different class of
people who could could turn it into the
business it is now I would say that
what's important not to do is is in
error many people make which is to focus
on either the squeaky wheels which can
take a lot of your time or to focus on
what school I mean usually what you have
to do is not what you want to do and
it's very important to be disciplined
about doing what you have to do and not
what you particularly feel like doing
that particular morning
are there certain characteristics you
look for in your early recruits in terms
of personal characteristics and and
skills to said really smart and
unquestionable integrity so they're
really smart I think is sort of obvious
the integrity thing is so much of you
know a start-up is about doing something
that's impossible and suspending
disbelief and if you're looking over
your shoulder at the next guy and not
sure if he's with you you're toast
so you've got to believe that you know
that they're gonna treat your partners
with integrity they're gonna establish
the culture so you want the culture you
want of integrity you want the board to
trust you so you need to be trusting the
information getting other people who are
sharing the board it's it's I think
people MIT I think a lot of people miss
how absolutely essential that is now if
you have people are really honest but
they're not sort of smart and
hard-working then you that doesn't work
either but boy I think people can really
miss the the central importance of that
and to your point about it you flog the
culture early if you don't build acting
with integrity and early you're dead and
that typically you can figure that out
is are people willing to do something
they don't want it you know tell
something the customer something they
don't want to hear or tell a board
member something they don't want to tell
us all some other constituency that
they're accountable to something they
don't want to hear if they can do that
then you know that's it that's a really
rare and wonderful characters I
completely agree with those two points
on that one one other which is that
often times people make the mistake of
wanting to find a clone of yourself and
that that's a mistake because you
already have the skills that you do and
what you want to look for is
complimentary skills so how did you know
who to go after first
in my own case it was it was pretty
obvious because I needed systems company
we needed at least one hardware guy one
software guy so those are the first
three guys I'm having a mashup of all
the people that you could have gone
after how did you know they were the
right ones to go out so this notion of
being able to cross somebody integrity
and of course unquestionably smart these
were the attributes I was looking for
and in the case of one of the guys one
of my co-founders beyond the interests
I'd actually worked with him so I knew
him personally and the other guy was
Dennis Ferguson and he is actually
unquestionably the the the the best guy
in the Robin protocol universe and still
you know has has an intuition in
networking which in my mind is unmatched
anywhere so I was actually lucky to come
across these guys with your people that
you work with that wanted to be part of
the team that weren't necessarily want
to have at the very beginning yes did
you bring them on was that the
developers from start to make money
getting angry but it points out
something that's useful so if you're
these guys who are sort of half of
brands in and of themselves
then it's relatively easy for them I
think to attract folks you want to work
if you were me who's essentially the
quote one of my board members sort of
Joe shut the Ragman trying to start the
company it's really you need to borrow
somebody else's brand to make you look
bigger than you are so you can attract
just actually I think with advantage we
got out of working with benchmark or why
I think it makes so much sense to work
with top to your venture because you
know if I'm Danny shader calling up and
saying hey you want to go do this thing
people know that that's a neat idea or
maybe they don't but I don't have any
faith in you but if I'm Danny shader and
by the way benchmarks backing me then
suddenly I'm larger than life than I can
attract a different class of talent and
that's a that's a really important
lesson I think for you know sort of guys
who are I mean come coming into this now
Mike you talked about stem for EE
professors why is that work for you well
again it's the class of ideas I like to
work on fairly new technical ideas and
Stanford EE I'm not sure its general
again you said you called your your
company de croo because you're getting
the crew back together again so beyond
what we have said the one thing I always
look for is the killer instinct there is
a certain class of people that no matter
how much money they have made no matter
where they were in their career they
think they need to do more and that's
something that you just simply must have
in a small company and by the way to the
point that Danny was making about saying
hey you know my name is Dan and
benchmark bacne that's great to get the
person enter into the room and then the
question I always finish with every
interview is why do you want to join the
crew whatever and if the answer is
because benchmark back to you I don't
hire that person I mean you want the
person to come because he believed in
the mission they believe in the team and
they want to be part of something great
if they think that because benchmarking
back to you you have a higher chance of
success which by the way you do that is
not interest compassion they got Fertel
know
what quality is overrated
so for me personally the main experience
so when Andy was kind enough to invest
in the glue it was started by two guys a
computer science professor at Stanford
med a ee professor and myself neither of
us had either storage or a security
background whatsoever the entire team
and then he knows us well the first 30
employees in the company all came from
EFI which means they knew all about
printer controllers again and your
nothing about storage or security the
interesting thing was at about a year
into it we knew more about storage and
more about security than people who've
been there the whole career in many ways
yeah but nobody storage specifically and
security specifically when you mor kind
of things about the sips and FS
protocols and people working and you
know on the flip side on all kinds of
esoteric features of their yes protocol
we just need more about it because we
had more talent how do you know that
communications hi I was gonna I was
gonna say exactly the same thing that
you know I think raw intelligence makes
up for a lot and I'll give you one
example early in the company we you know
SONET is one of the protocols that that
most wide area router stock and we were
having discussions with Lucent early on
and the evaluation team actually was
about twice the size of the company at
that time so we were 12 people 36 people
came to evaluate one of the pieces of
feedback that we got was you guys are
never going to succeed doing sonic
because it's taken us to you know eight
years to build solid gear and you know
we had exactly this experience that the
people that hired were good enough that
within a year and a half we had silicon
up and running and we actually found
bugs in the in the test equipment solid
testers so it's it's not that I agree
domain expertise is highly overrated I
agree I think you can hire your third or
fourth or fifth person on the company's
the domain expert not you want the smart
people to start migrating and domain
experts sometimes you know they're
they're fixed in their ways of thinking
about that set of problems and I think
that you know most interesting things
are done at the
section of two disciplines where there's
a lot of friction that far removed can
you be as the product conceptualized or
from the industry that you're pursuing
so while your recruits might you might
over value to conceptualize the
completely gone so that for my personal
experience when we started he if I came
from the Israeli military and people in
the office we're talking about
PostScript and I don't understand what
the big deal is but making little
letters you know at the back of the page
and they and it I didn't know what
PostScript was and then you know you're
an athlete or the fire turned out to be
the best printer controller out in the
market the same was true about the crew
we really didn't know all that much when
we actually knew more about storage
because we used it and security but we
don't know a lot more about it and
they're gonna think we're the point is
super important that people who have
been in space for a very long time the
people with cannon and Xerox PARC you
know there's been doing printer controls
for a long time had a certain way of
doing it and Adobe saying you know
silken graphics they're all people
computer with via find early days that
all of the main experience in the world
and they just add a different slant at
that which happened to be wrong it's
hard to take a non consensus approach
when you're steeped in that consensus
mode I think I'm testing in my mind
whether or not this this
question-and-answer though is biased
toward the product side because I think
we've made mistakes it good that we
wouldn't have made if we had more
distribution experience that had domain
experience you know I think we I think
well there's a lot of people right now
who have come up an IT who are now like
I am ending up in the cellular business
and there are all kinds of implicit
assumptions that we've all made an IT
about distribution and economics and how
things work that just get turned on
their head when you go cellular and I
bet we wasted 12 to 18 months trying to
convince the cellular business to act
like the computer business instead of
realizing we had to activate the
cellular business worked and so I think
that that when you're getting outside
the domain of Technology I think
understanding the market dynamics is
probably really valuable that being said
which don't want to have is somebody who
only has domain experience and doesn't
have sort of creativity and smarts and
the ability to
to sort of synthesize the way a market
works and some new rules that you need
to apply later my Calot how similar to
your original idea do your successful
ideas end up being when they come to
market different companies have had
different Rambis is pretty much exactly
what we started with it hasn't really
changed that much in the past 16 years
or so I mean it's evolved that it hasn't
changed that much matrix actually was
pretty damn close to when we started it
didn't change that much some of the
other companies did probably should have
evolved even more than what they did
actually so I think it varies from
company to company I think you have to
be flexible right in the youth what did
good start as Danny I was making mp3
player plug-ins for handspring advisors
and noé BlackBerry Enterprise Server
that was before you got those before I
got there but except comm started as an
escrow company and I think that scoop
everything was going to serve eBay and
we got jilted by eBay and found out that
escrow was worthless
so that was a it was a fairly radical
transformation in our brief history then
to person-to-person payments I don't
know if it is true but I just heard a
week ago that that skypes doubt it
started out as a file
computer-to-computer file transfer
program so that's an interesting change
of direction on that one so as soon as I
know a company that's working on
computer computer file sharing that
started because the guy was fascinated
in Skype then how did that color
management company evolve into building
print controllers for the copier so the
true answer is necessity because we
needed to survive the color management
approach was was about basically
convincing everybody in the world to
adopt a certain way of processing colors
and computers that means all the
software vendors all the hardware
vendors and all the printer vendors so
it turned out not to be and what
happened was if we want to just to prove
our concept so we bought a you
Kanon color copier for $7,000 and i
reverse-engineered it and figured out
how to make that color copier into a
color printer just so we can show he
refused our color magic technology here
the prints look just like they do on the
screen and so we had this great demo
going but still the hardware vendor
software vendor and all the above didn't
see our way but when we started showing
the basically color copier printing at
five pages a minute offset quality in
1990 people said can we buy them so this
is byte anyway interesting thing we had
was we had the first public showing of
this technology was in the basement of a
hotel in Boston and this guy was 26 at
the time he showed up in our booth and I
showed him a demo and then police said
I'm not leaving so you saw the demo so
what I want to take this with me look
this is only protect we have so long
taken with me so this guy basically
spent the whole day until basic I
promised them he can keep the prototype
so the prototype really never left
Boston what he did was he took that
prototype we put it in our bid square
and just between MIT and Harvard and he
opened this small store called page
works that they already had this photo
wasn't doing well but he started
printing basically called presentations
for professors and students the first
year I made a million dollars just
because he basically got this free heat
and that's what I'm going to throw out a
real business so if I went from five to
fifty nine year after year just by
basically taking this technology to
market an organized fashion secure how
different was it from the original video
you know the first product that we did
was very very close to the conception of
what the company started with and we
were actually lucky in that because it
was a fairly complex thing to do and if
we had to also change things along the
way it would have been very very
difficult of course the company is in a
very different place right now because
it's expanded that initial product into
a whole series of products and
how similar do you think the environment
is today to ten 15 years ago with regard
to being able to start something that is
a chance to grow to be very large if
times changed or the are the good days
behind it's easier now that there's
there's I think that the ideas can
happen faster and you know with the
internet and just general more capital
and so on so the ideas can happen fast
there's more people competing trying to
come up with the ideas but if you hit on
the right one you get the right team
things can happen a whole lot quicker
and I think no no I commit suicide
you know the Patent Office have only
shut down to begin a 20th century
because it was decree that there aren't
any more good ideas to come I have a
colleague here at Stanford who likes to
say that entrepreneurs are motivated to
change the world build a great company
or get rich do you agree
and which one is most important to you a
great company change the world or get
rich got a pick two out of three I mean
it's it's changed the world and get rich
I so have to say for me it's all three I
don't want to sound glib about it
because if you look at both the fi and
the crew they were kind of a change the
world type companies efi was about
convincing people to start printing in
color in the office instead of printing
in black and white and the crew was
about encrypting personal information
that people have stored all of the world
so that was a change the world peace the
second piece build a great company you
know you can't really change the world
or become very rich without building a
great company i mean it's just virtually
impossible to do and although a bunch of
entrepreneurs especially in business
school who think about flipping
companies to make money into flipper
company you don't have to build a great
one yeah you can do it for short or you
can turn and you can't become very doing
it so I have this interesting experience
because we did flip the company although
wasn't our intent and I was briefly
really rich on paper and in really
unhappy and then I wasn't rich on paper
anymore blended and but it was a it was
a really great thing to get to learn
early that that wasn't what was gonna
make me happy and then honestly the
reason I do this is I really like to
work with really smart people on
interesting stuff and I don't think
they'd be working with me if I were in
the job I'm in because they're frankly
smarter more capable than I am in doing
what they're doing but because I started
this thing or I'm driving this thing I
get to be with them and interact with
them sort of under the way that I kind
of want to do that under the terms that
I gets established so you know I don't
get to do that if we don't build a great
company because it won't attract and
retain those kinds of people and those
people I think for the most part wanna
make a lot of money because they haven't
had the experience I've had of realizing
it's not going to freaking matter but so
that's I think there's a fourth
condition there which is something to do
with how your viggo gets stroked by the
people you get to interact with we
started off the discussion with culture
/ deep you brought up can you build a
great culture if you don't have a big
hairy audacious goal I don't think so
for everyone matter if you don't have a
hairy audacious goal - I got a fourth or
maybe a fifth one and that's because I
think there's nothing more exciting than
working with the sort of the best talent
in the world and then making progress
that at a pace that that's best taking
so there's there's this magic that
happens when you put you know six or
seven great people in a room or in two
rooms and you're making progress
you know miles a minute it's truly yes
and also it's the difference between
selling all week where there and sailing
20 foot kind of motor yacht and you know
it's a different experience and there's
many people who prefer the OB cat
experience that's the type of people who
sit on the side of the table again
always exciting often fun what in your
backgrounds do you think was most
important to you becoming an
entrepreneur things are boring and if
you ask why I became because I'm a
terrible manager I mean I hate being
managed I hate people tell me to do it
automatically I look for every reason
possible not to do it so what happened
if I was very wise I said if you're so
smart go around the company yeah that's
how I find myself the CEO okay which HP
know do you admire the most is there
anyone you've modeled your careers so
high I have a brother-in-law who started
this set of camps in Palo Alto in this
area and I mean I think there's two
different kinds of entrepreneurs there
are what I call real entrepreneurs and
then there's institutional entrepreneurs
and I'm as institutional entremet which
means that I exist I'm a figment or an
artifact of the valley right I mean I
can't everything I've done is about
glomming onto somebody else's something
else and putting it together to create
something there's another class and I
like doing that and this is a great
place to do that that's distinct from
someone who conceptualizes whether it's
a product of Hitler but even those guys
you know Eric Hans of the world who can
where your colleagues yeah right exactly
but there's another group of people that
I have I have a huge amount of respect
for which are the guys who do that
without any infrastructure on them
people who create these businesses these
traditional businesses out of whole
cloth and I think of those are I think
those would be entrepreneur
entrepreneurs and I just have a lot of
respect for that because I can't figure
out how the hell they do it you know
there's no there's no things you can
hold on to to build yourself up now I
have a model Mike you know I model
myself off a completely different person
but but that's a that to me is you know
I always define tellers the thing I
can't do and I can't imagine doing that
so it's it's that's impressive to me
it's interesting because I agree with
what you just said that first I want to
say that I modeled myself on he wasn't
an entrepreneur in the sense that you're
asking about it guy named John cocky was
a IBM fellow smartest most wonderful
most inventive guy I ever met but he
worked for IBM its whole life you know I
think it was a question of times he
would have been a what was it that you
want that you most admired about him he
knew everything about every area that I
loved and knew more than anybody else I
know and you just he'd love to talk and
he had most interesting ideas of anybody
I've ever met in my life but just and
plus you know half the compiler
optimizations on demand for his idea
more or less directly and I'd like to
point out he never wrote a paper in his
life he'd come up with ideas and then
the people around he would get my rescue
every profess that people around he
would get so frustrated that he wouldn't
write him down that they'd write the
paper put his name on it for me
having a role model wasn't it was really
important and Andy baclofen was my role
model because we went to school together
he came over to Stanford
well to me I mean the biggest fear not
that I you know spiral model anything go
after the Steve Jobs is you look at
somebody who basically just really has
this greatness about and I think it's
jobs you know not just because he
recently so Pixar to Mickey Mouse I mean
so I saw Jobs a few times in there
I would say middle to late stages of
next and I think what's the point about
great entrepreneurs their ability to
face the person every is great when the
stock is doing this and the sales are
doing this and everything is going great
and you're in cover in time but you
probably remember Andy next that it
pretty rough going and you know kind of
three four years into it we went to see
Steve because he was trying to convince
us to run at the fiery software on the
next Hardware because we should really
build Hardware fortunately didn't take
that piece of advice but we walk in
there and we knew at the time that next
is not gonna have a happy ending but we
walk in there and we listen to Steve and
so he puts kind of on the board
convenience it puts Microsoft son Apple
and then he puts next and he says only
two companies are gonna remain about
being and this was time when Apple was
doing very well and son was doing very
well so it's a few years ago he said if
you basically think about which of these
companies is going to be successful in
the long term it's gonna be next and the
reason it's going to be next is because
we have the perfect marriage between
hardware and software and we really
understand how to go together and we sit
there for one hour we walked out were
completely convinced he was right
as you know he did this to Apple you
know he came in there it took a company
there wasn't a I mean freed I have to
end off he dies he righted the course in
our Apple as we all know it all-time
high in terms of stock market valuation
other company is a company currently
known as Pixar Pixar when stiva for
those of you don't know the story of
Pixar it's a very interesting story
George Lucas had a little kind of baby
company that was called renderman it was
named the product the company was called
Pizza yeah Renderman was basically
software that was supposed to allow
people to create movies and it was kind
of puttering around for many years and
then Steve Jobs when he left Apple
basically bought it like you know you
buy a car you buy the company thought it
would help next yeah but he brought from
self-identified as part of next to he
own and so I had this company and he
kept pumping it was a 10 15 20 now and
those of his money every single year and
you're talking about a guy his net worth
was big but not that big and at the time
you know it wasn't clear that next is
gonna have a liquidity event so he just
from his own checkbook kept writing
these big checks and then this guy here
and John Lasseter had this idea why
don't we instead of basically using or
basically instead of selling software
try to use the software to make a movie
and they made a movie and they partnered
with Disney to distribute the movie the
movie was called
Toy Story and the rest is history but I
mean this is true greatness you look at
to compare all three companies next
which he managed to get acquired by
Apple Apple which you turned around
dramatically and Renderman / Pixar
therefore they would have state of
course I would have never gone anywhere
I think this is the signs of true
greatness I agree but it's hard for at
least me to model myself
how did you know you were ready to be an
entrepreneur did you even think about
that
no it didn't it just seemed like it had
to be done I didn't there's just
inevitable yeah I just wanted to do it
and then that was in my mid-thirties no
there's a an HR consultant I like a lot
of them Debbie down to Willow who when I
said I was gonna leave to go do this she
said what's wrong with you Stanford MBAs
all of you guys at age 35 think you have
to go up and start companies but so I
think it was just you know but I was
what I always wanted to do it's why I
came here it wanted to be in the valley
I wanted to do a start-up and so I got
the opportunity to go to try to go do it
and I did so you're saying it's peer
group pressure for me it was time to do
it you just knew I just knew I didn't
think twice about it I I thought that
this this idea you know if I could see
it lots of other people could see it and
if I didn't do something about it I
would regret it later I did my first
company was in college at the age of 19
and company do all I mean what's ready
you know there isn't any GMAT test that
you do and together when you pass it
okay now I can be an entrepreneur it's
kind of something that you do something
that you feel exactly advisable is it to
start a company with a friend well so
you know visually I think he got very
politically correct answer for that
trick question I can give an example
which is the crew as handy well knows I
started the company with my best friend
who's a professor of computer science
out here and I mean if anything that
strengthened our friendship and again to
the point that everybody here made that
when you're working in a company mostly
as every VC will tell you after make the
investment only bad news come for a
while
find all competitors you forgot and all
the market challenges and so just two
guys in a stack of slides and the fact
that there is a person standing with you
in the trenches that you trust
implicitly it's just others by the way
the third employee in the crew is my
brother who was with me at EF I served
with me in the army so the feather just
have this team of people I've had my
worst experience with brothers because
that's the tough tougher bond I know
that husband and wife I know you know
business of breaking bonds if they're
obviously wrong it's very different it's
impossible to come between brothers that
takes all the emotions I tend to want to
partner with somebody who I know a
little and know enough to think that I'm
going to become friends with them as we
do the comprehensive no no no I think
that's that's been my approach you know
I generally don't know the people I know
them well enough to know that work but
I'm not necessarily friends with them so
let me try talking me into either
intuitive or thought which is no you
know I think the number one determinate
of six well the one characteristic of
all companies that fail is they stop
running
so you know the people are usually
comment on maintaining adequate capital
but the other thing you got to do for
long when you've got an intense spirit
and and so it's that relationship thing
that lets you keep showing up because
you know startups are you're a hero
you're doomed you're here you're doomed
in the periodicity stretches out the
ribbon so you've got to be in there with
you you gotta have the money but you
also gotta get any people you'd like to
go to work with every day because you
know otherwise you wouldn't stick with
it and then you will be one of the guys
who stopped looking and losing heart is
the losing heart losing capital kill you
I think why do you think immigrants
represent a disproportionate percentage
of the successful entrepreneurs because
they're hungry I think it's always been
the case I think so the obvious answer
to is that beyond that is that they've
already had to make one giant culture
awliyas so the other obvious leap is -
why should I work for somebody else I
could do my own I mean that's the leap
from one culture to another isn't
probably that much different from or the
willingness to did you even think about
that when you came here yeah but then
it's pretty obvious in the sense that if
you look a lot of the people who come to
America are basically the brightest
people from pretty big countries and
they're pretty big continents if you
look yeah there's you know not that many
Europeans have come here but the ones
that come here are the ones that are
entrepreneurial and there are the ones
that tend to be the smartest you know
the same mystery but people who come
from Asia and so you just have this kind
of influx into the Silicon Valley if
people from all over the world that come
here for the basically fact that this is
a land of a truly unlimited opportunity
and so I would say actually if you look
I think Americans overly proportionally
in you represent at the end the
entrepreneurial thing because there's
only 250 million Americans right and
there is a grand total
what the five going people in earth
right now and so if you look at the
month of great American trippin ORS it's
bigger than 250 million over five doing
I don't know what's this proportion it's
the immigrants of the Americans and they
enter me it's where the Americans have
disproportionately represented now for
the question I know you've all been
waiting for when is venture capital
appropriate well so if you're nobody as
early as possible that you need to
attract a great team because it's not
it's it's not not just the money it's
the branding of the money of your trial
make yourself seem larger than life to
get a great you sound like I'm tonight
well because there's this one of your
partners is fond of saying there's two
kinds of people in the world there are
product knickers and there's sort of
everybody else and the product pickers
are the guys like you you know you can
put them in a room and they'll just keep
inventing new ideas I thought I was one
of those guys until I realized I wasn't
but I still wanted to do this stuff so I
had to go get around those people and
there's no way you know people are
attracted to ideas I had to get them
attracted to something else and so I had
to borrow somebody else's brands and I
think that's a it's worked for me it's
work for other people I know who've done
that so I think that's it
if you're of the non-product bigger
school go early and you all know what
product what deity means by phone a
clicker explaining well the notion of
upon Pickers there are just people you
meet who are always inventing great
ideas if I did it is they're creative
but they also somehow me to market and
they meet a market before the market
exists and they're people there are
people you can go make entrepreneurs and
residents and they don't need any
outside stimulus they'll somehow on
their own invent new ideas you know the
could frankly Marc mike is the one of
them I there's two guys I always think
of a group that this definition of core
3 Mike Jeff Hawkins and a guy named Eric
Han who's on our board and those guys
you always keep that your last name has
to start with each yeah but that's a
that's a special thing and it's a fairly
rare thing and I think if I'm a venture
guy I want to get to know those guys
because you can build companies around
the particularly if the model is that
guy gets an idea gets a Stanford
professor and you build an entity around
and off you go but there that's rare and
I don't think if you have
entrepreneurial leanings you should skip
the dream of being an opener because
you're not that guy particularly if you
live here in the valley where there
where you can synthesize all these other
things around you in order to give
yourself a platform to get to work with
those kinds of people but another way to
think about it is in order in order to
create a new business there needs to be
changed change creates opportunity we
find that market sensitive technologists
are able to recognize an inflection
point in technology and how that might
be used to solve a particular problem
that needs to be solved that nobody has
to date been able to solve and three of
our demos today I would say that is
their fundamental value added is their
ability to foresee inflection points and
how that can be used to sell quickly
because in pradeep's case the recognize
changes in computer architecture and how
that could be applied to the networking
space where no one else they've been
doing that because of the work that
you've been doing on creating new
classes of servers isn't free so that's
what our firm at least what we mean by
product pickers there are market
sensitive technologists who can
conceptualize compelling new ideas that
take advantage of a change what is it so
back to the venture capital question
well I think that any entrepreneur that
begins a company without venture capital
is a fool and I'll give an example of me
even if they're going up to a small
market people here are that interested
in but if you're going after if you want
to start a grocery store be quite hard
to get benchmark to vacuum
you could start any company wanted from
his own checkbook or duty estrin right
then to destron could have started any
number of companies from wealth and
frankly when we started the crew we
could have written a check and start the
company venture capitalists do add value
and if the good ones and one of the
things that's very common around the
kirpan noises they fall in love with
their own ideas in a big way and so the
guy the main founder of EFI did to
basically try to start the company
without venture capitalists he had this
love of the whole color management we
wasted two years you know and a lot of
money of his money basically trying to
figure this space out ya know Silicon
Valley venture group was interested in
back in the company to town as you what
we call and then we kept with the
biscuit is kind of a pretty controller
thing then all the venture capital the
interest started spiking so I would say
that venture capitalists have a very
good sense for market and I don't think
anybody is that smart the way they come
with that yet say well you know this is
going to change the world and so having
a team of very smart people a helping
you basically with the business thing
makes sense or not is super valuable
because I always thought people look
when you can always make plenty of in
the future that one thing you can never
recoup is time so if you spent five
years of your life on a company that
never had a chance to survive at the end
of that you're five years old and you
have five years less to work so if you
come to Andy and Andy looks at this and
then his polite way he tells you look
and I'll come back when you have a
better idea
you said it's nicer than that but that's
the message if you go back and come back
with a better idea in most cases and
then when the company gets going beyond
just the brand of the VCS the VCS create
a very elaborate service I would say
kind of network around them so I'll give
you an example recruiters recruiters are
basically the type of people that get
all the money for the product before
they ever show you the product the way
is it right now you pay hundred thousand
dollars and throw a little shop with a
great VP of Sales now there
the stream has never been clear to me
and so if you as an entrepreneur go and
call up a headhunting shop and says you
know send me a VP of Sales you'll get a
very good looking yeah you'll get a very
good looking person will come and take
your hundred thousand that's probably
last you'll see them however when Andy
calls up the head until they know that
Andy's going to give them many more jobs
because Andy's not working on one
company's working on seven eight or ten
at a time and so they're not going to
alienate any so they're actually going
to work hard to deliver the good product
the same is true about law firms or
investment banks by working with a group
like benchmark you're sure you always
want to get the top of the top of the
service providers and there is this
whole industry that's built on the back
frankly of entrepreneurs of all these
service providers and most of the people
in those service industry companies are
not very good and so you need the help
of a firm like benchmark to get the best
service from the best people you know
that's certainly been my experience also
that you know before being associated
with kleiner and benchmark and any it
was very very difficult to get anybody's
attention at all and once I was
associated with those companies it was
night and day and if you really want to
make your company go fast I think
there's not a better way to do it and
going slow is really sometimes deadly
because other people have the idea and
go faster so I can give so I actually
very strongly agree about how much to
help because you're right I can't
gentleman Ford to fund my own companies
and I've done it once or twice and the
results have been fairly big Stan so
what I've come to conclusions even more
strongly what you just said if Bruce
Dunleavy doesn't like it but I don't
think I want to do it his partners is a
great well with that let's open it up to
questions from the audience
you know when I was building the
engineering group I actually looked for
first made a list of the expertise that
I really needed and then went out and
looked for the best people like a think
off and literally the first probably two
to three hundred hires at Juniper were
all people that were known to the early
folks my first name and actually mostly
people that had actually worked with us
so there was no question of whether
could this person perform under pressure
it was a given I'm not a testament to
the people that you had though do you
think that that's the normal case that
an engineering team can find can build
itself purely my personal relationships
I don't know Andy that's this is the
only case I do know so it's hard for me
to judge what the normal cases yeah if I
were definitely you know we just got to
this country so obviously our people
from ads in the newspaper and
headhunters and that took a very long
time I mean I took this probably six
months to put together a team of five
engineers well that the crew we
basically had thirty engineers working
in the room within a month it's easier
when it's from the people you know just
to comment real quick I actually don't
like to hire teams of people I like to
hire individuals and sort of mix things
up a little bit so all my all my hires
were individuals and actually teams have
this problem that they have an internal
dynamic which you then may have to
adjust because the environment is
different we do it this way where we
came from exactly yes
so you find from unmagical for you to be
see what did you learn and as we see did
you hire you and see yeah I would never
hire myself Amanda to be a pain to
manage so whatever it is that Andy is a
very rare exception in the sense that is
a person who grew up his whole career as
a financial investor and I think that
very few people today are in the venture
business if you look at people with
Andy's Stryker could have grown up with
that background if you look at some of
the greatest people in the business like
Don Valentine or like John doar they all
work for them and so and so the point is
that you basically what you apply is you
kind of apply your experience over the
years to help companies out and it's
very important to note that most of the
great companies are started by people on
this point yeah now these people don't
have any fear they don't know what's
impossible on the flipside they're
hungry they're hungry they're willing to
work incredibly long hours because they
don't have children and in many cases so
that's a good thing the bad thing is I
have no experience and they're going to
make a lot of mistakes you always make
so actually prepared by the answer to
what's the biggest mistake I've ever
made and I made it consistently time
over time again and everybody I know it
makes that mistake which is you can
never fire somebody who too soon it
never happened that if I had a question
mark around somebody and I took my time
but firing person it goes with me so I
would say the number one thing that the
venture capitalists can help is they
don't have any emotional ties to the
employer
executive population so they look at a
person that was not performing and I
would say generally the venture capitals
the good ones have the sense was not
working much sooner than the CEO does
and they said look you know this person
is just not working out you know
interesting point is if you look at
really successful companies built large
and independent business seldom are they
run by a second time CEO in almost every
case they're run by someone who is a CEO
for the first time it's really
interesting because is because typically
they're on a big fast track when we
recruit them where is the people that
you can that it's hard to get someone
hungry enough the second time around
that they're going to sweat the details
and such and so it's this is a
fascinating discussion we got with
recruiters does the venture industry
follows a normal curve like jebby of any
other industry and the people who are in
that middle the lower part of the curve
all want gray-haired retread CEOs and
they're not the ones who are going to
drive the interesting new market and new
business so I'd rather bet on these guys
every time than I would on someone who's
done it before
for technology business it's imperative
you know a lot of venture capitalists
like to back their own ideas they almost
always fail because if we can figure it
out it's too late it's too obvious so
you know if you're working in the
industry you figure it you see that
inflection point well before anyone else
but importantly I don't think that means
you can't do it what it means you got to
go find the guy a partner you gotta go
find the partner you deal with pardon me
stop tough mistakes the topic of the
panel miss naming campus I could give
you one answer at least for me and that
is after you've had a one or two
companies that have been successful what
tends to think you can try and do maybe
two or three companies at once doesn't
work at all it's a really bad idea you
got to do one any time it's a little
different it's a little different
please you need hiring two junior is
that I think is a if you're a you know
less the senior person starting these
companies you you may not reach high
enough for whom you hire or even most of
the goods executive staff is not the
original executive staff that I
recruited and that was a that was a we
lost time and I think I could have done
better you know my worst mistake I think
was bad hires you know especially in
critical positions bad hires
are hard to recover but if you have a
great product market fit you seem to be
a you said covers lots of sincere
well I can give us an example you know
an investment made by one of my partners
which is a company called phone calm
which returned about 200 X on the
investment so when that idea came around
it was in the early 90s there was idea
was basically allowing phones to have
internet access at the time the phones
were these you know kind of like phones
exactly bricks and they didn't exactly
do much hell alone do the internet and
my partner basically went to a few
potential customers and also not to do
that and so he decided to back a company
anyway and it was a great return so it's
very hard to validate these things
because like Andy said them the way you
make the really great because when I
didn't really have market yet and so you
just have to go with your hunch I mean I
was always intrigued by another of
Andy's partners investment twist wasn't
a guy that was basically marketing Pez
dispensers on internet or allowing
people the trade Pez dispensers on the
Internet and somehow turned out to be a
pretty good investment but I think it's
still the number one best venture to
never write even yeah it's critical but
partly at least for me if you're not
absolutely sure you know at least what I
usually come up with something up I am
so convinced that there's a market there
that I hear on the side of not being
willing to listen to people who tell me
that there's not and I mean right I mean
it takes a lot of convincing to where we
try and believe that there's not a
market there I'm a vicar yeah I don't
know if that's you know you might be
able to say more generally you know the
IBM's take me about we listen to our
customers it's the worst thing you can
do
startup because they're telling you to
solve yesterday's problems me and as a
start-up you're trying to solve
tomorrow's problem so to a large degree
you can't listen to the customers and if
they all say they like it
like when we incubate companies we
suggest that they go out to five
customers if all five say they like it
we know it's not a good idea because
it's too late
somebody else has to be doing it if it's
obvious enough that all five think it's
a good idea if everyone hates it that
might not be a good sign but if one
other five who is a credible person says
you know there's a pony in there that to
me is the best thing because if you
think about the investment business you
can characterize it by a 2 by 2 matrix
you can be right or wrong consensus
non-consensus Danny C heard this in my
class big weirdo business goal yeah so
if you're if you're wrong obviously you
don't make money whether if your
consensus or not consensus but what most
people don't realize is if they're
you're right and consensus you don't
make money because the returns get
arbitrage dawei the way you you succeed
is by being or succeed big is by being
right and non-consensus and as special
what makes an entrepreneur special is
the ability to foresee a problem that
they can solve that others just don't
see and it's something that I have
unbelievable respect for and why they
are far far more important than the
venture capitalist
no I wanted to be what did I bring in
the table I mean I think this word is
used pejoratively but I don't mean it to
George I think I'm a promoter at the end
of the day I I can sell other people's
ideas and I can sell other people's
ideas to other people and by the way I
can only do that if I happen to believe
in the idea myself so if I can't invent
it if I hear something and I'm really
really excited about that I can I think
generate that enthusiasm and other
people are around me and I I suspect a
lot of people here who can do that and
that's a good thing to do because there
are many people who can come up with
really great ideas but they can't sell
them
that's the first time I think look
anybody who can anybody who can create
something out of whole cloth is a
rockstar in my mind regardless of what
they're doing and so or where they do it
so I think that's straightforward and
that's for the winner petrol money is
going right into further well the reason
that we invest in technology companies
are why they have tended to be the best
investments is that intellectual
property significantly reduces the
amount of capital that's required to
build the business unless you're in our
business well most gross margin is the
best funding source on earth then how do
you get the highest gross margin it's
the highest value add you know one of
the things that characterizes these
peoples products is high value add high
intellectual property might talked a lot
about that early on and so if you're
going to do something in technology
you're probably best off doing it where
the the whole environment is best suited
to it and nothing can come close to
Silicon Valley
you can't make near the returns because
they don't have the intellectual
property which allows the gross margin
course it's a different business at
least right I mean people are making a
lot of money in China and I think the
moral equivalent or immoral equivalent
of electro property there is connections
connections connections well it's gonna
be different firms it's not gonna be the
same firms evolving it's gonna be
different from who know how to play that
game definition technology changes you
know 150 years ago technology was a
train what's technology wherever there's
intellectual property that allows for
there are some other places doing pretty
well
Israel is doing reasonably well
relatively small areas to Israel that
has more companies listed on NASDAQ than
any other nation except the United
States on NASDAQ but and so but it was
not a developing country I think maybe
another way to answer this gentleman's
question is that venture capital firms
work for investors I mean now there is
basically a layer of investors invest in
venture firms and then invest in the
venture firms because our specialized
instruments particularly towards
technology investments so if we or
benchmark suddenly start making all
kinds of weird investments and I don't
know textile manufacturers in Shenzhen
they're gonna say look this is not what
we basically back you guys for
so profit covers for a lot of things but
the like they don't think but exactly
what they like good is very low you know
it's actually a very careful
consideration because if it's an idea
that once you describe it to somebody
could be replicated very easily you have
to be really careful right but if it's
an idea that depends on execution then
you can be pretty free about talking
about it because you know you have to
have a confidence that you can do it
faster than somebody else because you
understand most about it
this what was in my case was the idea
dependent very heavily on the execution
I think people get backed with the
kernel of the idea I don't think it has
to be all thought through but as long as
there as long as you can see what the
inflection point is what's the point of
pain that allows one to build something
sagina market that could grow to be
something significant we figure out all
the details later because if you get
product market fit right you can screw
up almost everything else
it was and actually a lot of people
advised that it was a you know highly
foolish thing to attempt I think you
know that's where you have to trust your
own intuition because if it's an idea
that you come up with and you've
explored it to some detail nobody
understands its idea better than you do
so in my case I was the whole spectrum
was agree I never run the company so I
can start so I can get a second that I
can come a little bit next to Mike
because I ran the company for the first
six months and I knew that I didn't have
the confidence to run it at scale so
very early in a company you look look
for you know hiring a great CEO and so I
think it's really important to
understand your own weaknesses and
sometimes people one of the biggest
reasons for conflict between founders
and VCS is typically the early folks
want to run the company when they don't
have the confidence to do it so I was
looking at this back to Andy's point
about the first time SEOs if you look at
Michael Dell Steve Jobs from Bill Gates
Larry Ellison ended up running company
yeah they ended up running the companies
to youth skill and so definitely a lot
of people up and down Santo the founders
typically needed to be taken behind the
barn and shot it's actually an
expression but one of the very famous
venture capitalists um you know and
they're really kind of classic cases
it's not true
I mean there are examples like Cisco
which went through a pretty big change
at the top pretty early on in the
company but majority of companies that
are super successful the founder ended
up being the CEO so you're in the early
stages where you're trying to hold it
all together everybody's looking at you
and they're studying your body language
or even subconsciously interpreting your
body language by how confident you are
in what you're doing and yet somehow you
and you're not always confident so
somehow you've and if you're
bullshitting they pick that up too so
somehow you have to sort of suspend
disbelief yourself and say I can freak
and do this and just do it I think as
long as you possibly can till either you
run out of steam you lost spirit and
hopefully you picked that up early or
the board or the board fires you which
is you know saving yourself I think
because I think if you if you stop
trotting
you can you can maybe think you can't do
it but many things almost the people
Taipei Zoo around here all at some point
thought they couldn't do something that
kept powering through it so the trick is
to just keep trying powering through it
power through listening learning and
growing and then just somebody will take
you out or you'll give up because it'll
be no or you'll give up Google too hard
so I think you I just come back this
thing it's so important just keep
showing up I just want to tell a little
story because I you know we we sold so
except calm was PayPal nine months
before PayPal and and by the way it was
a product picker Eric Conn who was
sitting on her voice saying that esker
idea is terrible I just want to email
money from one person to another and we
the key to that business is the
mechanics of moving money is easy the
trick to that business is controlling
fraud it's knowing that the person
you're taking money from this who you
think you're taking money from the vice
versa turns out that the trick to credit
card fraud but what huge advantage of
credit card fraud would be if you had
the chargeback histories from a lot of
credit cards so when Amazon decided to
go enter
the auction business to compete with
eBay they were going to use their
traditional model of making it easier to
buy if therefore they want to do
one-click payments they've started
looking around for a payment company and
pretty soon there was just us because
our product thicker had done this idea
before anybody else did about it and I
chickened out because I thought oh [ __ ]
if Amazon comes and does this with 11
million credit cards at the time they'll
cream us of not realizing that we were
27 people who were maniacally focused on
this problem and Amazon was joined to a
lot of stuff and when we got acquired I
mean the you know and it was it was a
fine deal and a good return to investors
but we give up you know I my first shot
at the deck and I chickened out and sold
we walk in the door and the first thing
we found out is didn't have any freaking
chargeback histories yeah there was all
they could do didn't ship books on time
and nobody was even thinking about it
had we just stayed focused you know we I
think we had a real we might have blown
it but we had a real shot and all we
have to do is just keep showing up so
good technology right which I've now
been at for more than five years and
it's an unbelievably huge valuable
market opportunity that is exceptionally
hard it's fractally hard every time you
go do something there's five more
problems that reveal themselves but
we're in it's now the point where with
the only guys left other than research
emotion and the lesson that I've been
applying to this is I'm not going to
make that mistake again
so we're just going to keep showing up
and showing up and showing up in low and
behold the other guys lose spirit lose
capital are gone and you're the last guy
standing in a real market opportunity so
one more question and we hit you what
else yes
the biggest firm is the market you get
that wrong they're toast and I think
that's a good summary for the panel so
please join me in baking